I want to thank President Biden for
giving us this opportunity we come from
a country that's really poor and we're
looking for work
illegal border crossers praising the
president's border policy as Fox News
cameras capture the extent of the crisis
watches migrants climb over barbed wire
and shipping containers it's a scene the
president did not witness during a short
visit on the border on Sunday before
heading over to Mexico to address
immigration with its President Fox News
contributor in retired acting a ice
director Tom Holman joins us now good
morning Tom
good morning good morning so what did
you make of that the the president went
to the Port of Entry he met with the
people serving the migrants but he never
saw any of the migrants and then that we
have video of them or pictures of them
cleaning up the streets the day before
they were really messy full of trash the
next day they were clean
you know I was hoping the president go
down there make a meaningful trip but
it's you know it's just another
political stock it was a photo op he
went down to empty streets empty migrant
centers he went to the power to border
where there's a border barrier where
obviously a secret service audio safe
when there's a border Bearer get that
and and understand what's going on in
the Border what he did is did a photo op
I'm sure he's going to announce his you
know run for presidency this is nothing
but a political stunt he didn't go down
and talk about how to secure the border
and what he should have done from the
time he landed is apologize to the men
and women the horse Patrol who who he
slandered from the White House Podium
because he still hasn't even announced
that those men were innocent put him
back to work he should apologize to the
first speech he gave as president where
he said the men and women the last
Administration to watch children starve
to death on the banks of the Rio Grande
this is talking about 20 000 men and
women who saved lives he he should
apologize for signing 90 executive
orders that abolished the most secure
Board of these men and women ever had in
he should have spent a few minutes and
asked why there's 14 suicides of border
patrol agents in one year try to
understand that to see if Washington can
help with us I'm not saying the historic
border crisis caused a suicide but it's
certainly weighed on these men and women
who ever had had some sort of internal
struggle he had an opportunity to honor
the men and women who stand on that
front line and defend this nation
instead he went down there and
disrespected them and and chose to see
what they did what they're not dealing
with every day it's disgusting Marcia
Blackburn is touring the border with a
group of other other women senators and
she said this fiscal year alone remember
it started in October they apprehended
143 individuals convicted of crimes here
in the U.S we have a picture of a
machete guy down there on the border is
attacking the migrants using this
machete and robbing them they're
trafficking humans they're trafficking
fentanyl the border crossings are
dangerous not only to Americans but also
so to the migrants
when you make promises you can cross the
border illegally be released in the
United States when you tell ice they
can't arrest you because you're simply
hearing legally the most vulnerable
people in the world are going to put
themselves in the hands of criminal
cartels to come to the greatest nation
on Earth there's already there's already
been over 1700 migrants dead on U.S soil
which is a record by fire Right add that
to over a hundred thousand Americans
done from fentanyl this administration's
policies are killing people let me say
this President Trump when illegal
immigration was down 83 percent how many
women weren't being sexually assaulted
how many migrants weren't dying how many
pounds of fentanyl weren't getting into
the country because we had a secure
Border in the border patrol is Vigilant
on the line president Trump's policy
save lives President Biden's policies
are killing people at record numbers I
know when they hear it down in Mexico
and other countries that our borders
open they send many of them are sending
unaccompanied children can you imagine
doing that being so desperate in order
to save those lives just do it the right
way thank you so much Tom
thanks for having me you're welcome I'm
Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm
Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis